[musique]
tel avec la Crimée
le sirop est venu à Kiev quand j'avais 19 ans
J'ai maintenant 34 ans mes parents sont venus
immédiatement sauf
sami est venu en russie moi papa criméen
Tatar et je dirais que tu vas
là de Russie
ennuyeux savent que les transporteurs cachent leur
sentiments et c'est une rue
ne fume pas maman il me semble que
fille intelligente
un
[musique]
envie de bouger pour se cacher
pour 6k être un certain temps très
ce que nous pouvons trinité
[musique]
alors amis du 21ème siècle
Sous-sol de la ville de Kherson
la plupart ici ont déjà donné naissance à l'ensemble
petits enfants et ici nous avons 2
en chemin
dis bonjour s'il te plait
[musique]
très 10 cm
il y a
[musique]
tout ce que je veux dire, c'est que xii relation
très efficace c'est cette génération
qui grandit déjà sera avec haine
5 à ce pays, c'est exactement un fait
en général, oui, l'enfer sait comment je le veux
que la Russie soit la dernière à refuser
maladie ou affecté la moitié de la tour
chemin
le ministère des affaires étrangères de l'Ukraine ce sont nos terres
[musique]